ça c'est le masque qui jeu mais quand je
sors dehors ya une ventilation par un
boîtier de piles qui ici on qui permet
d'allumer le ventilateur donc ça permet
d'essayer de l'air à l'intérieur parce
que sinon ben ali vers ça fait de la
buée et l'été il fait beaucoup trop
chaud l'hiver je met des gants normaux
en laine et tout ça il était dit
qu'enfin nom mais qui laisse pas passer
les uv quand même et après je mette la
vaysse donc en digne parce que le jean
c'est pas très épais c'est pas très
chaud mais ça laisse pas passer des
cimes exposé aux uv dans un premier
temps ça me fait des tâches mais pas à
la seconde près ça va arriver
quelque temps après quelques mois et si
à un moment j'ai trop de tâches et
qu'elles sont trop graves bas ça peut
faire des cancers de la peau
et
toutes les fenêtres par exemple mon
collège ou de ma maison
on a mis des filtres anti uv qui font
que les uv ne peuvent pas rentrer à
l'intérieur du coup j'ai pas besoin de
porter de protection c'est plutôt quand
je sors dehors que là ya une différence
c'est que je dois mettre une veste des
gants tout temps des pantalons et va et
surtout une bulle pour la tête qui
ressemble un peu à une bulle
d'astronautes bel adulte il mesure c'est
de vérifier les fenêtres on voyait ricky
d'abord avec le 2é m c'est une petite
machine et c'est là que ont vérifié le
tortueux et donc les ailes sont pas
bonnes donc il va falloir fermer les
fenêtres fermées en corée puis
[Musique]
en tout c'est la rentrée
normalement ça veut dire que c'est que
c'est la pièce elle est bonne et capa du
raid dans beaucoup des bas dans les
couloirs pas trop mais c'est il n'y a
pas beaucoup de salles de cours où je
peux l'enlever bas c'était surtout
ancien que c'était difficile où shell
pas trop du coup c'est pour ça qu'on a
placé les autocollants avec la lune et
du soleil
mais maintenant je sais
je sais où c'est bon et c'est pas bon
parce que j'ai repéré au collège
maintenant ça va boire après
au niveau des plus beaux ici par exemple
de ceux qui sont à l'étoile des fois ils
me regardent un peu parce qu'ils savent
pas trop ce que c'est ce qu'on leur a
pas trop expliqué mais sinon au collège
ça va
[Musique]
photo yd passé parce qu'on regardait le
décollage et là on a vu l'équipe sortir
avec une protection pour la tête alors
pas celle qui met pour sortir en dehors
de la station spatiale
celle qu'ils ont mis quand ils seront
montés dans l'ailé dans les voitures et
là je me suis belle et là la version de
leur bulle elle est vachement plus
dizaines que la nôtre elle est ovale
eh bien il faut à tout prix qu'on arrive
en modèle thomas pesquet quand même
français on a de la chance
d'où vient sa bulle ces parties de large
est né désespère pas un jour peut-être
de le rencontrer et humour à quoi va
déjà je montrerai ma protection
d'enfants de l'alu et je proposerai de
l'essayer une sage pour répondre aux
gens qui me disent ah bah oui en
astronaute et je connais ton map
esquisses et donc ça pourrait un peu
leur chaut avec même un ventilateur à
baillif on dort à équipes au sol un
oui c'est moi qui l'ait fait et puis
comment le casque le tissu coûte cher
c'est que les parents n'ont pas des
dessous ils économisent il arrive à
changer il faudra parents pour leurs
enfants
moi je n'aime pas quand les enfants ont
un truc et ali mais sur la tête je
propose aux mamans d'apprendre à coudre
et alors expliquer comment faire à une
protection face il est comme ça les
enfants peuvent choisir le tissu et ils
peuvent changer à chaque saison ils
peuvent être accordées à leurs blousons
à leur robe
ils ont un événement et les enfants sont
de plus beau et quand ils sont plus
beaux et ils sont plus contents
[Musique]
si vous voulez aider aussi les enfants
de la lune c'est aussi en les
accueillant faut pas avoir peur ces
enfants une fois qu'ils sont dans
l'école ils sont comme les autres et il
apporte un regard sur la différence et
les parents sont toujours touchés de
dire à mon enfant est comme les autres